[Musique]
mes amis
voilà impliqué dans quelque chose
d'horrible
il n'y a pas de mots pour exprimer cette
chose
je voulais utiliser le mot bestialité
mais non
l'homme est pire que les bêtes les
surpasse dans toute l'immensité de
l'enfer
j'ai le droit d'écrire cela après ce que
j'ai vu
et ce qu'il s'est passé
à auschwitz
[Musique]
ces mots
sont essentiels à notre mémoire
collective
ce sont ceux du capitaine little de pied
les deux skis
un officier de l'armée polonaise
entrer en résistance contre les nazis
sa mission
infiltré à auschwitz
septembre 1939
la pologne ou cèdent sous la charge
combiné de l'allemagne nazie et de
l'union soviétique
abandonné par ses alliés français
britanniques elle pleure plus de
soixante mille morts
varsovie s'est effondré
son indépendance obtenue 20 ans plus tôt
lui est arrachée
[Musique]
sur la voie royale l'occupant allemand
humilie la nation polonaise les troupes
du reich parade devant hitler en
personne
mais sous les doigts des allemandes
des hommes de l'ombre s'organise déjà
il y avait véritablement un état
clandestin au pologne qui se structure
très rapidement il ya le gouvernement
polonais en exil qui va être d'abord en
france et ensuite à londres et qui va
coordonner la mise en place de tout un
ensemble à la fois de noyau de
résistance qu'on pourrait qualifier de
résistance armée mais en même temps
qu'une administration shirin
souterraines
[Musique]
dès les premiers jours d'occupation
la résistance imprime une presse
clandestine
et prépare ses premiers sabotage
parmi les meneurs du mouvement
un certain witold pilecki
capitanat réservistes de l'armée
polonaise
patriote il se démarque des communistes
et des nationalistes
avant guerre c'est au bureau de 38 ans
produit d'être f le rouge
il vit sur ses terres avec sa femme
maria institutrice et leurs deux enfants
enjoy et zofia
piles et ce qui nourrit des idées
sociales novatrice pour l'époque
tobo genre il était à la fois militaire
et activiste social
pendant la période de 20 ans ou la
pologne a été un pays libre il a créé sa
petite communauté
quel est ce qui a créé une association
agricole uniterre ton pied une
coopérative laitière un bataillon de
réservistes plein de choses qui
manquaient dans le pays
c'était un homme de devoir
il me disait toujours si tu crois que tu
ne pourras pas aller jusqu'au bout de ce
que tu entreprends mieux vaut ne pas
commencer
à la chute de varsovie vital de pilotes
ce qui enlève son uniforme d'officier
pour endosser les habits de la
clandestinité
et il y en a tous les atouts
il était très sportif
c'était un athlète qui prenait soin de
sa forme
il se déplaçait aussi silencieusement
qu'un chat
quand on dînait avec ma mère il entrait
sans faire le moindre bruit
ils restaient dans l'entrebâillement de
la porte de la cuisine à nous observer
quand enfin on se rend des comptes on se
mettait à sursauter en criant tu es un
fantôme
dans la famille fantôme est devenu son
surnom
de nid même voyage à jeudi
pis les tic au fond d'une faction de la
résistance polonaise qui comptera
jusqu'à quinze mille membres
[Musique]
il découvre les premières applications
des théories raciales nazies
[Musique]
pour le reich les slaves ont le statut
d'une thurman ch
de sous-hommes
il ya la hiérarchie raciale qui a été
définie par le nazisme et qui est
relativement simple au sommet vous avez
la race pure la race germanique vous ce
qu'on appelle communément les aryens est
au plus bas vous avez quatre sous
humanité qui sont dans l'ordre
d'une part les slaves suivi par les
asiatiques
ensuite les arabes et enfin les noirs
plus bas encore les juifs
si les j sont des sous-hommes dont il
faut se débarrasser on sait pas
exactement encore qu'est-ce qui a
derrière cette idée de se débarrasser
d'eux les slaves eux doivent servir en
fait d'esclaves au
aude asie
dès septembre 1939 les nazis lance lynn
telecare actyon
plus de soixante mille personnes sont
arrêtées en quelques mois
ces hommes ont tous un point commun ils
font partie des classes dirigeantes
polonaise
philips qui se cachent pour échapper aux
rafles
dès septembre 39 une directive de
heydrich
impose finalement la liquidation des
élites polonaises ce sont les officiers
de l'armée polonaise ce sont les cadres
de tous types les professeurs
d'université
les enseignants les curés tout ce qui
peut incarner un
semblant de cadre social qui forment la
nation polonaise entendu non pas
uniquement au sens de polonais mais les
juifs sont concernés les et craignant de
pologne sont concernés tout est liquidée
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait dans
l'esprit nazis l'idée d'exterminer
toutes les populations
slaves mais l'idée qu'il ne puisse pas
dix ont relevé la tête et reconstituer
une nation oui et même s'il y à du
travail forcé ou d où des exactions
elles n'ont pas pour finalité leur
disparition
le 14 juin 1940 des prisonniers de
guerre polonais sont transférés par les
nazis
ils quittent leurs geôles surpeuplées
pour un endroit que
la résistance polonaise veux découvrir
ce que tu rames l'occupant
[Musique]
et libéré les détenus
un homme se porte volontaire
vital de piles et de ski
sa mission infiltrer à auschwitz
[Musique]
à mon avis il avait le sentiment que
c'était son devoir en bouche et il
pensait en être calme humble alger pour
trafic ou tension au pic
jeu
avec ses aptitudes hors du commun et son
expérience il était le seul de la
résistance à même de recueillir des
informations à auschwitz
et c'est pour ça qu'il a pris cette
décision
au sein de l'armée il a été formé pour
être à la fois espions et éclaireurs
il avait un don qu'anticipé les
mouvements de son adversaire
de plus mon oncle était un excellent
psychologue hills avait recruté des
hommes de valeur des incorruptibles
pile et ce qui laisse derrière lui sa
femme maria ainsi qu'en jaye et zofia
âgés de 6 et 7 ans
je ne sais pas dit je préfère aller où
je suis plutôt que de rester avec ma
famille il n'y a pas de problème ça a dû
être un choix très difficile mais
l'attachement à la patrie et
l'importance de sa mission l'ont emporté
guide il était très religieux
il croyait en la force de la prière
il croyait fermement que duale et le
guider pour accomplir cette mission
divine se sont rencontrés
pour infiltrer à auschwitz piles et ce
qu'ils décident de se faire arrêter à
son tour
le 19 septembre 1940 il se rend chez sa
belle soeur et son neveu marek
grâce à son réseau d'espions il sait
qu'une descente de la gestapo est prévue
ce jour là dans leur immeuble
je sais bien qu'à le concierge ian
williams qui
qui faisait partie de la résistance
court vers eux en criant monsieur witold
des allemands sont en train de rafler
les hommes dans notre quartier nous
avons une excellente cachette dans la
chaufferie
lui a répondu
merci mais cette fois je ne vais pas
l'utiliser le concert j'étais stupéfait
qu'est ce qui lui prend qu'est ce que
c'est que ce caprice
ce n'est pas un caprice mais bien le
plan de piles et ski il se fait
embarquer avec 1800 personnes
dans un train
[Musique]
si l'écrasement et le manque d'air et
est telle
que les prisonniers mouret pendant le
voyage
une fois arrivé dans un lieu qu'on ne
connaissait pas
la porte du wagon s'est ouverte sur une
rangée de ss de chaque côté
ils portaient des fusils et des fous et
il y avait des bergers allemands
[Musique]
pilez ce qui est jeté hors du wagon
en un coup d'oeil en un cri il comprend
que sa mission n'a pas lieu sur terre
mais dans ce qu'il appelle
l'enfer
[Musique]
non seulement les ss nous frappaient sur
la tête avec les crosses des fusils
mais toutes nos idées nos concepts sur
la vie
la société sur terre
tout cela s'effondrait de façon brutale
[Musique]
il essayait de nous atteindre de façon
radicale de nous briser mentalement
les triais
aux tortionnaires tout en nous frappant
criait et sk y logent les semailles
lieberman
pilote qui entre à auschwitz avec les
autres hommes
on
leur demande quel est ton métier j'ai
prêtre
suite quel est ton métier enseignant
wall street
quel est ton métier d'ouvrier relations
qui est interné pour bourgogne et du
talent
en tant qu'officier piles et qui
comprend qu'il va droit vers la mort
il s'invente un métier technique pour
survivre
[Musique]
il reçoit un uniforme aux rayures bleues
et blanches
ornées d'un triangle rouge deux
prisonniers politiques
comme ces milliers de co détenus
[Musique]
privé de toute possession
ces hommes sont également dépouillés de
leur identité
[Musique]
à auschwitz les noms sont interdits pour
achever de déshumaniser les prisonniers
désormais les toiles de pilates ce qui
sera numéro 4859
esclaves du reich
[Musique]
on leur donnait un numéro sur un petit
bout de 4
il devait le tenir entre les dents
méthode pilates guy mais vital de
pilotes ce qui l'a gardée dans l'âme un
chemin en ouvrant il a été frappé au
visage avec une matraque par un gardien
ça lui a coûté 2 heures 3 end
seulement dedans comme il le raconte lui
même
le discours du lager fureur le chef du
camp
traces ensuite son destin
le chef du camp fritch a fait son
allocution
il nous a dit vous êtes dans un camp de
concentration
la discipline stricte aucun d'entre eux
n'en sortira vivant ce qu'ils sont juifs
vous avez le droit de vivre 14 jours
les prêtres et
les autres 3
sous les yeux de pilates ski toute
l'étendue du projet à auschwitz
ce chantier permanent est déjà le plus
grand camp de concentration et de
travail forcé du reich
[Musique]
jusqu'à vingt mille hommes ils seront
détenus sur une surface de 20 hectares
les industriels allemands espèrent
profiter de ce réservoir de main
d'oeuvre
himmler va très tôt décréter que
auschwitz constitue le porte étendard
pour la reconquête allemandes vers l'est
on va voir les entreprises allemandes
s'installer un énorme développement
économique industriel
agricole
milliers se développer un peu partout et
donc le travail est réel avec un élément
très important pour les ss si un détenu
meurt c'est pas très grave il sera
remplacé par un nouvel arrivant
à 5h45 du matin le gong retentit
pilate qui rejoint la place d'appels où
se tiennent des milliers d'autres sommes
parfaitement alignés
[Musique]
la moindre défaillance déclenché les
coûts furieux des capots
ces détenus de droit commun allemands
chargés d'encadrer les prisonniers
au début la principale tâche des ss et
des capots étaient tués
chaque kapo avait le droit de tuer un
prisonnier juste parce qu'il ne l'aimait
pas
ils tuent essentiellement des gens qui
ne travaillent pas assez vite
[Musique]
parmi ces chefs
ernst bachmann
un barbier berlinois de 45 ans condamné
pour violences conjugales
il terrorise jusqu'aux autres capot
[Musique]
la vue d'un homme tombe en gémissant en
des crampes man fou
il sautait sur la poitrine du prisonnier
donné des coups de pied haut rhin et aux
organes sexuels le tuer de la façon la
plus rapide possible
ce qui échappe à la folie de crâne woman
rejoignent au pas de course un commando
de travail
et comme la plupart des prisonniers
piles et ce qui est affecté à la
construction date fixe
pendant cette période les prisonniers
travail est majoritairement à
l'agrandissement du camp en construisant
de nouveaux blocs et en ajoutant des
étages au bâtiment de plain pied
quand j'avais 18 ans je devais porter
depuis le wagon des sacs de ciment qui
pesé jusqu'à 50 kilos quand un homme
tombé sous le poids d'un sac et beaucoup
n'ont pas résisté les ss lui tirer
dessus il disait que l'homme n'était
plus apte à vivre dans le camp pour y
travailler
c'était dans de tels moments quand un
prisonnier a été achevée que nous nous
reposions pour quelques minutes
reprenant notre souffle et ralentissant
notre rythme cardiaque
nous étions comme des animaux
à bout de force après 16 heures de
labeur pilote qui est les autres détenus
rentrer au camp
escorté par les ss il porte les
dépouilles de leurs camarades morts au
travail
à auschwitz même les cadavres doivent
pointer pour l'appel du soir
[Musique]
quand les capots partait avec 100 hommes
après l'appel du matin et qu'il revenait
à la fin de la journée avec son homme ça
voulait dire pour les ss qu'il n'avait
pas travaillé sérieusement
mais s'il revenait avec 90 hommes
ça voulait dire que c'était de bon capot
shields qui titube jusqu'à son bloc
avant le couvre feu
chaque bâtisse abrite jusqu'à 1200
prisonniers
qui s'entassent pendant des mois sur le
sol
puis dans des lits qu'ils auront
construit
ils sont plusieurs par niveau
les vivants
partagent leur couche avec les moore
vous assistiez à l'agonie prolongée de
votre ami
c'était comme mourir avec lui
votre existence c 'est aussi
mais peu après vous vous sentiez vivre
ou plutôt revivre
et lorsque vous mourrez comme cela à
près d'une centaine de fois
inévitablement vous devenez différent de
ce que vous étiez sur terre
les conditions d'hygiène sont
effroyables il faut plusieurs années
pour que des toilettes soient installés
ainsi que des auges pour que les
prisonniers se lavent succinctement
typhus
dysenterie les maladies se propagent
pis les skis survie de justesse à une
infection pulmonaire
sous alimentés malades les prisonniers
dépérissent
matin nous recevions en 2000 être dans
liquide qu'ils appelé café
sorte de substitut
à l'heure du déjeuner nous avions droit
un litre de bouillon
soupe
le soir et il nous donnait entière de
niche de temps
prélève d'être c décider de qui vivait
et de qui mouraient le vol de pain était
passible de la peine de mort dans les
camps tant par les autorités du camp que
par les prisonniers
dans le camp apparaissent des
silhouettes squelettiques
trop faible pour travailler trop exténué
pour manger
trop usés pour survivre
une pensée commune émergeait nous étions
mis par notre rage notre désir de
revanche à partir de là je me suis senti
dans un environnement parfait pour
commencer mon travail
et j'ai découvert en moi une sorte de
substitut à la joie
c'est grâce à cela que je ne suis pas
tomber dans le désespoir
il fallait combattre pour survivre
pilate qui font de son réseau de
résistance
la z os w
son plan de bataille est déjà prêt
il doit créer un réseau d'hommes fiable
chargé d'infiltrer tous les commandos
je suis informé la résistance polonaise
et les alliés de ce qu'ils se déroulent
à auschwitz
il espère déclenché une mutinerie pour
libérer le camp quand varsovie en
donnera le signal
[Musique]
sur la bear canal est derrière les blocs
piles et ce qui commence le recrutement
[Musique]
chaque fois qu'ils se dévoilent à un
autre détenu il risque sa vie
[Musique]
vitol qu'il est ce qui a été employé
dans différents commandos de travail à
auschwitz
et tout en travaillant dans ces
commandos il observé soigneusement les
autres prisonniers
si l'un d'eux gagner sa confiance
alors vital pilette qui lui proposait de
le rejoindre dans son organisation
clandestine
il choisissait très scrupuleusement ce
qui allait le rejoindre
il a organisé la z os w en plusieurs
cellules de cinq personnes
chaque membre devait se charger d'en
recruter cinq autres
et grâce à ça beaucoup de gens échapper
à l'arrestation il sait nous éviter
d'être infiltrées par les nazis
en cas d'arrestation par la gestapo de
trahison il n'y avait donc cinq
personnes qui tombait ce pas
cuisine et tables menuiserie
l'organisation de pilotes ce qui
infiltrent les commandes ou les uns
après les autres
il était avantageux de choisir comme
membre de l'organisation des personnes
occupant des postes de commandement
un chef de chambre et qui avait prêté
serment pouvait donner de repas
supplémentaires aux plus faibles
on pouvait aussi lui envoyer des
camarades il les laissait se reposer
dans la pièce
pilate qui comprend que pour survivre
dans le camp il faut travailler dans les
commandos les moins difficiles
afin de protéger ses hommes il approche
le chef du service du travail auto kuzel
31 ans
le détenu numéro deux est pourtant un
capot allemand
un vol à la sauvette à berlin l'a
conduit de kankan à auschwitz
l'homme est les nazis
[Musique]
japon
il savait qu'il ne pouvait pas aider les
prisonniers les plus âgés
j'avais beau mais les plus jeunes je
suis de 20 25 ans
ce que justement
c'était possible de leur permettre de
survivre à auschwitz tout d'abord
je ne faisais que 40 kilos
afin qu on accusait lé jeu m'a vu
il m'a dit eh toi numéro 918 va dans ce
commando match
donc j'ai découvert que
ce groupe travailler sous un toit
grâce à sa petit à petit j'ai repris des
forces
[Musique]
pile et ce qui s'attaque ensuite à
l'hôpital du camp
il donne l'ordre un membre de la
résistance le docteur voix dit soif des
rings de l'infiltré
des rings vol des médicaments destinés
aux ss et trafiquent les registres
d'entrée et de sortie pour protéger les
détenus les plus faibles
[Musique]
parmi les hommes sauvés par la
résistance qu'elle gymnase pierre of
skin
[Musique]
gg pour l'oc
un prisonnier polonais est venu me voir
quand j'étais malade
il m'a vu et m'a dit de retourner au
bloc
parce que le lendemain l'auberge tome
fureur de l'hôpital allait revenir et il
était connu pour nettoyer l'hôpital
après chacune de ses venues
ce qui signifiait qu'il allait tuer les
prisonniers qui n'avait pas l'air bien
oui ce match
[Musique]
le réseau de pilotes qui atteint
progressivement plusieurs dizaines
d'hommes
et le doute s'immisce dans l'esprit des
allemands
ils repèrent des vols dans leurs bureaux
s'étonne de ces détenus qui survivent
plus longtemps que prévu
la gestapo est sur la trace de piles et
ce qui est des siens
[Musique]
devant le bloc 15 une boîte à mouchard
apparaît
la gestapo promet de récompenser tous
détenus qui dénonce ses camarades
le camp joseph chacun d'entre nous
tester le caractère de chacun
certains ont glissé dans un égout moral
d'autres ont vu leur personnalité est un
seul et comme du cristal
pour piler de ski commence alors une
bataille du papier
l'organisation pilotes ce qui a fait un
double de cette clé de boîte aux lettres
les conspirateurs l'ont ouverte lui les
dénonciations jeter celle qui mettait en
danger d'autres prisonniers
pour neutraliser les mouchards le réseau
créé un tribunal clandestins
alors que la journée les nazis tue sans
distinction la nuit les traîtres sont
jugés
des détenus essaie d'éliminer les hommes
les plus dangereux les mouchards ce
qu'ils font peser une menace les capots
les plus violents on s'en occupe quand
c'est possible quand il n'y a pas de
danger pour le faire quand on peut faire
disparaître le corps deuxième hic des
ces décisions n'ont jamais été prises à
la légère tu es le corps
était longuement réfléchi
les membres du réseau débattez entre
pour condamner un prisonnier
il fallait recueillir de nombreuses
preuves contre les
tags et govou
en pleine épidémie de typhus
les hommes de piles et ce qu'ils
prélèvent des poux contaminés sur des
malades pour les disperser sur les
vêtements de leurs cibles
[Musique]
cap aux traîtres et ss infectés sont
envoyés à l'hôpital où des rings et les
siens les attendent
absence de traitement au surdosage
l'élimination est intraçable pour la
gestapo qui redouble d'efforts pour
détruire le réseau pilée de ski
elle interroge des résistants dans la
prison du camp le bloc 11
surnommé le blog de la mort
quand vous passez à proximité
vous senti une odeur similaire à celle
d'un abattoir un petit ruisseau rouge
s'est collé le long d'une rigole
cette dernière était régulièrement
nettoyés avec de l'eau de chaux et
presque tous les jours le ruisseau
serpenter à nouveau long des rives
blanche
derrière des grilles habituellement
fermées
les résistants appréhender rejoignent
d'autres condamnés à la peine capitale
le ss structureur gerard balic les
attend
surnommé le boucher par les détenus il
se vante d'avoir exécuté lui même 25
mille prisonniers au mur de la mort
au bloc 11
ali que j'avais un revolver avec un
silencieux
il le place est ici contre la nuque du
détenu et appuyer sur la gâchette auld
et rigole
le sang gicler par les yeux
la bouche
par le nez de partout
il tombait raide me
balic à tuer comme ça plus de 350
personnes en une seule journée
kazemi hp rove qui chargeaient les
cadavres sur une charrette pour les
conduire au crématoire
il fait en même temps le décompte précis
des morts
car pilotes ce qui prépare la deuxième
phase de son projet
informée la résistance et le monde libre
de la réalité des crimes commis à
auschwitz
[Musique]
avant tout chaque groupe de cinq
devaient observer ce qu'il se passait
autour de lui
notre mission était de récolter un
maximum d'informations précises sur à
auschwitz
devions les passer à notre chef de
groupe qu'il est passé à son tour a pilé
de ski
[Musique]
ces informations étaient compilées dans
son rapport pour londres
en novembre 1940 pis les qu'ils trouvent
un moyen de contacter le monde extérieur
un détenu libéré grâce à son influente
famille apprend par coeur le rapport qui
lui transmet
arrivé à varsovie l'homme le récital à
résistance qui le fait aussitôt parvenir
à londres
c'est le premier rapport sur le camp
piles et ce qui lève le voile sur à
auschwitz et adresse une requête aux
alliés
bombarder les infrastructures du camp
[Musique]
le bombardement aurait tué autant de ss
que possible je détruis la clôture du
camp et par les interstices de la
clôture les prisonniers auraient pu
essayer de s'échapper
bombardé de 41 c'est pas possible ni en
tirant denis en 43 il faut attendre
l'été 44 pour que les alliés sont en
mesure d'atteindre à auch 8 ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
bombardé quoi bombardé l'est quand vous
allez tuer les prisonniers donc ça n'a
aucune espèce d'intérêt et bombardé à
auschwitz à cet égard n'apporte rien
d'autre que de tuer les gens qui sont
déjà victimes des nazis
[Musique]
le rapport se termine par cette phrase
personne ne mourrait en vain si cela
signifiait la fin d'al fritz
et le 15 janvier 1941 les britanniques
oppose une fin de non recevoir
qui ne parviendra jamais à pied les skis
[Musique]
pourtant à auschwitz la machine de mort
s'accélère sous ses yeux
quelques mois après l'invasion allemande
de l'urss
dix mille prisonniers de guerre
soviétiques arrivent dans le camp
ils étaient liquidés par épuisement
mauvais traitements et par la faim et le
froid
parfois et prisonniers étaient en sous
vêtements ou complètement nu dehors
pendant des heures
les allemands riait en disant que les
gens de sibérie ne devraient pas
craindre le froid
nous entendions les hurlements de ses
hommes
je l'en jusqu'à la mort
[Musique]
les détenus soviétique s'apprête à faire
l'objet d'une expérience nazis
tuer quelqu'un c'est traumatisant
et donc qu'ils vont essayer de trouver
un moyen pour couper tout rapport entre
la victime et le bourreau pour protéger
le bourreau
le 3 septembre 1941 piles et ce qui
apprend que six ans officier soviétique
et 250 polonais sont conduits au bloc 11
cependant plus aucun à travers les
fenêtres des cellules les nazis ont
envoyé du gaz puis ils ont observé
minutieusement le résultat si la
quantité de gaz était trop faible ils
augmentaient les doses
ce fut le premier massacre à auschwitz
commis avec du zyklon b
puis un jour de novembre
pile et ce qu'ils observent plusieurs
centaines de soviétiques nu
poussé vers la morgue et les fours
crématoires
une scène terrifiante matériaux cas que
l'homme peut être naïf devant la mort
au début je cru qu'on allait leur
distribuer des vêtements
mais pourquoi les acheminer vers les
fours crématoires
en fait il s'avéra a causé des justement
pour gagner du temps que ces prisonniers
furent conduits là
on les enferma
tu toi
un récipient de gaz fut lâché
puis des corps dont certains frémissait
encore sur jeter sur les grilles
incandescente des fours
ce sont des gazages
expérimentaux mais ils sont
quand même lié déjà au meurtre de masse
puisque c'est à peu près la même période
qu'on expérimente sur des juifs des
camions à gaz en serbie et que va être
mis en fonctionnement le premier des
centres de mise à mort et à partir de ce
moment là le gazage va être utilisés
pour liquider
certaines catégories de détenus en
l'occurrence en cas de certaines
politiques comme la 14h13 qui est la
liquidation des détenus inaptes au
travail ou la 14h14 c'est le nom de code
pour la liquidation de certains membres
de l'armée rouge c'est-à-dire des
soldats soviétiques
[Musique]
en mars 1942 à auschwitz est temps
encore
birkenau surgi de terre
quatre fois plus étendu que le camp
principal ce nouvel espace
concentrationnaire est conçu pour 125
mille détenus
[Musique]
à peu près
quinze mille prisonniers de guerre
soviétiques vont être amenés à dire que
nao et ce sont eux dans des conditions
terrifiante qui vont commencer
l'aménagement
de birkenau qui devait être un camp de
d'un camp de prisonniers de guerre un
stalag pour prisonniers de guerre
soviétiques
c'était ça la destination première de
birkenau
mais à partir de 1942
birkenau camp de concentration
devient également un camp
d'extermination
les nazis vont procéder à échelle
industrielle à l'assassinât systématique
et programmée de 900 mille hommes femmes
et enfants juifs
c'est la solution finale
entérinée lors de la conférence de
wannsee le 20 janvier 1942
c'est à partir de wannsee en fait que va
être décidé la
déportation des juifs de toute l'europe
dans une idée qui est pas tout de suite
formulée enfin dans les idées quand même
qu'ils doivent mourir
la machine de mort ne fait que démarrer
bord
à auschwitz c'était une chose à l'habile
comme et birkenau
touch2o c'était une énorme machinerie
quand on roule et jean était consumé
gazés
au camp de concentration principal
pilote ce qui est averti de ce qu'il se
passe à birkenau son compagnon de
résistance jan karski a été transféré il
lui transmet les informations
nécessaires un nouveau rapport qui
parviendra à londres par l'intermédiaire
de prisonniers évadés
pile est ce qui le premier a
véritablement informé de l'assassinât
des juifs à auschwitz il comprend que à
trois kilomètres du steinacker autrement
dit à birkenau il est en train de se
mettre en place l'assassinât de masse
des jus
il y avait beaucoup de femmes et
d'enfants dans les wagons parfois il y
avait des petits dans des berceaux
il devait ici terminer leur vie tous
ensemble
ils étaient acheminés comme un troupeau
d'animaux à l'abattoir
[Musique]
femmes et enfants d'un côté comme de
l'autre aller dans des baraques supposés
être des douches
c'était des chambres à gaz
c'est sur la base notamment des
informations que fait sortir pilati que
fin 1942 le gouvernement polonais en
exil va publier une brochure qui
rapporte le sort des juifs et
l'assassinât de masse des juifs dans le
territoire polonais
il est ce qui bien sûr comme
pratiquement tous les prisonniers
étaient convaincus que cette nouvelle
était de la plus haute importance
il croyait que la quasi-totalité de la
résistance polonaise
du gouvernement en exil et des pays
alliés la traiteraient avec une extrême
attention
ils imaginaient que libéré les
prisonniers
au moins améliorer leur sort
deviendrait enfin une priorité pour les
années
face à l'ampleur du drame humain piles
et ce qu'ils espèrent passer à la
dernière étape de son plan
déclenché une mutinerie au camp
principal
couplée à une attaque terrestre de la
résistance polonaise et un bombardement
des britanniques il imagine venir à bout
des ss
libéré auschwitz
depuis quelques mois nous étions
capables de prendre le contrôle du camp
pratiquement tous les jours
nous attendions l'ordre de le faire
comprenions que sans lien avec
l'extérieur notre action serait certes
d'une grande surprise pour le monde
entier et pour la pologne mais elle ne
conduirait qu'à un beau feu d'artifice
il nous fallait le soutien et l'ordre du
haut commandement de la résistance
et la tentation nous hantait tous les
jours
le monde libre reste muet
tandis que la machine de mort nazis
continue de tourner à plein régime a
inexorablement
[Musique]
on mesure dans les rapports de pilates
ski ainsi que dans les récits de
nombreux anciens prisonniers leur
terrible déception leur désillusion
toutes ces informations sont parvenues à
varsovie et jusqu'aux alliés et rien n'a
été fait
philips qui conçoit alors une idée folle
peut-être pourrait-il convaincre lui
même la résistance polonaise et les
alliés mais pour cela il faut s'évader
dahouche fritz
[Musique]
en 1942
sur 170 tentative il n'y en a eu qu'une
douzaine de réussi
mes piles et ce qu'ils croient comme
toujours en sa bonne étoile
[Musique]
avec deux autres prisonniers et un arrêt
jane et dagg chelski il décide de passer
par un atelier
l'endroit est idéal il est situé à trois
kilomètres du camp principal
dans la nuit du 26 au 27 avril pile et
ce qui passe à l'action
[Musique]
boucherie donc plein de sous à 18h30 au
godinho o'shea les skis et ses complices
ils sont partis au travail avec l'équipe
de dire
il était assigné un atelier qui
préparait du pain pour les prisonniers
ils avaient avec eux un double de la clé
qui ouvrait la porte arrière de la
boulangerie
mais là rien ne va se dérouler comme
prévu
tout d'abord les gardes ont été
remplacés il est ce qu'ils pensaient
qu'ils auraient à faire un groupe de ss
âgé qui avait pour habitude de
s'endormir tout de suite après avoir
dîné mais ils ont été remplacés par des
jeunes gardent toujours sur le qui vive
puis ensuite c'est la clé qu'ils avaient
qui n'a pas fonctionné
impossible d'ouvrir la porte
je poussais non seulement avec tous mes
muscles mais aussi avec l'impulsion de
tout mon système nerveux et la porte
semblait plus forte que nous
enfin de façon soudaine et sans bruit la
porte s'ouvrit grand devant nous un vent
frais carré salle au visage en feu les
étoiles brillaient dans le ciel comme
autant de clins d'oeil
d'un bon nous avons sauté l'un après
l'autre dans l'obscurité les ss ont tiré
nous courions nous courions nous
fondions l'air de nos braille de nos
jambes
nous eûmes de la chance de ne pas être
touché
après neuf cent quarante sept jours
d'enfermement à auschwitz
pilate qui retrouvent la liberté avec
ses deux camarades
[Musique]
les allemands ne parviendront jamais
à remettre la main sur les trois
fugitifs
[Musique]
après l'évasion gillett qui a contacté
des unités de résistance
ces unités était caché dans la forêt
autour d'un gîte à auschwitz il avait
besoin du soutien de l'armée à craiova
la résistance polonaise
support n'est jamais venu
qui se rend compte que le plus important
c'est d'écrire son rapport pour
témoigner de ce qu'il a vu
avec cet ultime rapport
pile et ce qu'il veut achever son
témoignage
puis il reprend les armes pour combattre
le reich
en 1944 il participe à l'insurrection de
varsovie
mais le rideau de fer s'abat sur la
pologne
shields qui voit son rêve d'un pays
libre et démocratique
s'écrouler
cette fois encore il refuse de fuir
après les nazis il entre en résistance
contre les soviétiques
jusqu'au 8 mai 1947
[Musique]
appréhendé par le régime communiste pile
et ce qui est torturé plus de 150 fois
et meurt fusillé pour haute trahison
son nom est bannie des livres d'histoire
il faudra attendre 1990 pour que vital
de pied les death qui soit réhabilité
comme un héros de la seconde guerre
mondiale
comme l'homme qui a infiltré à auschwitz
[Musique]
m